it's time for the launching conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the app a presentation of the
lawn gene which nor wats company maker
of launching the world's most honored
watts and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lon gene
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
evening mr. Hardy Burt author and
correspondent and mr. william h currents
jr. military editor of Business Week
magazine our distinguished guest for
this evening is general Lewis be hurshe
director of selective service general
are she what you say in what you do
these days sir is very important to
quite a lot of people say the least now
with President Eisenhower's recent
action on promoção there quite a few
authorities who believe that there will
be a quickening of action and foremost
sir more aggressive policy I know that
you can't give away any plans to the
enemy but could you answer this question
will there be any stepping up of draft
requirements and the forthcoming year
for more men be needed well yes they're
going to be more men needed however we
knew it long before General Eisenhower
President Eisenhower has stepped up the
present situation because men went in
soon after Korea started those men are
now coming out and they have to be
replaced that's going to take more
people than we put in last year so the
answer is yes but the reason I either
don't know or think is no well the
Communists aren't going to learn
anything from your on front of scope I
can see that now there be 53,000 I
understand inducted in February's I
drive safe that day now is this very
much higher than the
average four inductees well it's 25,000
or so higher than July but it's only
6000 higher than December and January so
by and large it's not far from the
average of 50,000 about what we figured
we'd have to end up this year do you see
about 53,000 a month being inducted for
the rest of the year at least that many
and if it changed I would think it would
go higher rather than Lord do you expect
that it will go up to the eighty
thousand a month level of them no i
don't i think 60,000 would be high what
is the reason for this need for the
increased need for directories well when
they started out after Korea our first
job of course was to build and also
maintain but main a maintenance is a
very small factor at first but now
maintenance is the whole factor because
with a two-year term men are going out
very rapidly cuz they went in very
rapidly two years ago how many men do
you figure you will lose over the coming
year from there you know I've heard
different estimates and nobody can guess
because there's many factors involved
but i'd say maybe 100,000 well is this
increased the stepping up of the number
of inductees coming in is that going to
affect people who have hitherto been
deferred oh yes inevitably because one
of the reasons that people have been
deferred of course there's more than one
reason the one reason has been that we
haven't been able to take only about so
many and of course you defer some people
though you won't have to have two men in
1a and our potential has fallen from
about 3 million 6 to about 1 million two
and hence by the very mathematics of it
we're going to have to search in the
deferred classifications for additional
man well I see Sir now let me ask you
this if I were sitting out here and
watching this program on television and
I would refer it in the draft I would
ask a very important question and I
don't know whether you can answer this
or not but can you tell us which of
those now different are most likely to
be brought in no I don't believe a cat
this is true however that in the first
place if I were over 26 and became over
26 before june nineteen fifty-one I
wouldn't worry because the Lord makes me
not live if I were a vet
I shouldn't worry now if I am however a
deferred man or one who has been
rejected in 4f or one who was in 1a I
would worry about the inverse order in
which i've named well in other words
general we mentioned earlier that they
were considerable number of men who have
been deferred are they allowable up to
age 35 as I correct yes anyone that's
deferred before he gets to be 26 in
gains nine years of additional liability
that is regardless of their deferment of
the reason for their deferment a general
law there might be one solution of this
problem I can't advocated it but you did
and the universal military training
program I think you've cleared the for
Congress and wanted that program last
year is that right well yes last year in
several years before I've been for a
sense by 19 8 one of the things
complicates it now is that we have other
things to do it it isn't quite as easy
to institute although it is possible to
instituted are you still for it
absolutely now what is your
interpretation of a universal military
program you've got one now in effect I
mean right we have it now and it's just
a question of in another year or two
practically everybody will have been
inducted and therefore we will have had
universal training unfortunate president
I'm we were only inducting for a couple
years service and when the man comes
back and goes into the reserve he
doesn't obviously want to be Remo belies
where as if he had a shorter term of
training he could be held to a longer
period of well it liked the farm and
being in the firehouse ready to go well
I know there are quite a lot of people
particularly mothers who are very much
opposed to universal military training
and as a matter of fact in his Baltimore
speech President Eisenhower said that he
wasn't in favor of it but I wonder if
you would like to give the arguments for
it as you seen it well I I don't
remember i didn't hear the Baltimore
speech but as I remembered the question
was whether or not you could have
selective service in universal military
training simultaneously I am NOT I'm not
so sure President Eisenhower said he
wasn't for UMD I think it was a question
of time rather than effort now I I'm
been for universal training because I
think that death we we in wartime or an
emergency always require our young men
discern and I've always thought
only their that they have a chance to be
ready to do the things the government
required of them and one of the things
about it if you have something it's a
little harder than other things I think
it's in a democratic state it's better
to pass it around and not try by
mercenary means to hire somebody to do
the unpleasant things well do you see
any chance at all of the Congress
passing a universal military training
program this year well I think there's
all of the chance I don't know how good
it is and I think there's two ways to
institute if one is to institute by
additional legislation there there is to
use the legislation which you already
have well your present authority to
drought expires in 1955 and that isn't
the liability the extends but the right
to call anybody expires in 55 I don't
want to be too technical about it but
that is true well then any kind of a
universal military training act would
have to take effect after that date know
that I don't have that there's
difference of opinion there but I happen
to believe that we could start no.22
putting some of our people into a
reserve with a seven and a half year
liability after six months of training
that's it well going back for a minute
to a deferment question of how about
occupational deferment do you see any
decrease in deferring mem for work
apprentice work farm work or anything of
that old well I think inevitably if
we're going to follow out the
legislation to Congress passed a
universal I want to repeat universal
military training a service act now the
Congress did not defer anyone except the
ministers and divinity students and they
exempted those I think the Congress gave
the president power defer with the idea
that they could have a fluid a flexible
method by which each in their turn might
serve without too much disturbing the
public entities and I'm not so sure that
anyone is going to be deferred
throughout their entire period of
liability now general of course that's
logical i want to ask question about
this deferment to its logical that an
engineer will be deferred before say an
art student a student of engineering now
with a poor or a bad student of
engineering be more likely to be for
deferred than a very
student of Arts well I think you're
being a little unfair the engineer
called in the first place I was a
liberal arts students not an engineer I
don't happen to be a specialist and
therefore I probably have a little
feeling of frustration my question is
prejudiced or far well no I'm I'm
prejudiced and I think that do it we
need one thing we need now a lot of
people to know how to govern ourselves
because I think there's a greater need
for that there is things in the physical
sciences but I'm not joined in that
belief but the majority of people now
this white prejudice here's another
subject general it has happened is human
nature I suppose but I've heard more
than once complaints from parents and
from boys who did not want to go into
the service right now and they said that
the members of their draft board were
prejudiced and that just because this
fellow parted his hair that way they
didn't take him and because I sons hair
was part of the other way they took him
now what do you what about this
prejudice on draft boards I haven't
heard anything about corruption but what
about prejudice well of course in the
first place as a board is administering
a law the board didn't place the
liability on the lad the Congress did
the Congress said he'd serve it did say
that the president might issue some
orders about when he would serve and the
the fellow who serves on the Selective
Service Board has the rather hard
responsibility of carrying out a law
which did not defer people and I think
after all that we probably have
prejudice but on the other hand I think
the local draft boards through the last
13 years they've done one of the most
remarkable services in trying to do
without pain without anything except the
knowledge of having well done a very
difficult service namely to keep their
armed forces during the war to 12
million or so and now 23 million six
well quite frankly have you seen any
evidence at all of corruption among
these boards I mean a board member
accepting money to defer somewhere no it
we've had I think a half a dozen or more
people tried in 13 years I see well now
sir about about this corruption business
about this favoritism business each
board doesn't operate according the same
set of rules does it
oh that's a set of argument a question
what is rules what's policy and what's
the implementation of policy I never
have believed in uniformity because
there isn't any such thing as uniformity
among human beings but as far as having
the same general policy and followed in
the same philosophy I don't think
there's any question there are a few
exceptions and then when there are
exception we have the right of appeal
very freely given general one had to
take the local draft board you can
appeal to the appeal board without a
reason nice and that gives you two shots
just one final question and very quickly
general we hear a lot about the
disadvantages of being drafted or and
why people hate to be drafted how about
some of the good things about being
pressured well I think the man
participates and the most significant
think of his time I think he goes out
feeling he did his share and he didn't
try to push somebody else in his way and
if you want to get any material things
he's got practically three years of
education coming to him on Uncle Sam I
see Sir well our time is up now we want
to thank you very much general RC for
being with us the opinions that you've
heard our speakers expressed tonight
have been entirely they're all the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn gene krona scope was mr. Hardy Bert
and mr. william h Kearns jr. our
distinguished guest was the honorable
general Lewis V Hershey director of
selective service